wow I Wrestled a blind guy before I lost
no wow the blindies they're good yes
High School the ref was also deaf so the
way this guy speaks dude I don't know
where I don't know why I think you
joined the wrong division the ref was
death you can't understand what he's
saying he was like okay
it's like that like that right and then
I was like What He Blows the Whistle
this guy immediately goes for a double
then the ref comes boom literally pins
me like 30 seconds I get up I'm still
confused as to what's going on my coach
is like you lost I see that wrestler get
walked to the side and his coach is
gonna give him Skittles he goes like
this and then the Skittles are dropping
on the floor and I was like shut up I
swear to God
so the coach is blind too no and the ref
was like I said hear the hands all about
all his hands